oh man yeah oh man
fight
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
week Feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined for a very special
edition interview with video game Legend
Ed Boone he's the programmer voice actor
and director best known as co-creator of
the iconic Mortal Kombat fighting Series
in his latest game Mortal Kombat 1 is
set to release on September 19th Ed Boon
welcome to the show very happy to be
here a little nervous but uh it looks
like fun all totally normal reactions
you know everybody that comes in here
they're always nervous but before we get
started how are you around spicy food
like do you reach for hot sauce
naturally no I am at the lowest end of
the spicy food and it's not like I
dislike it I just have a uh a very low
tolerance so this should be interesting
[Music]
okay
foreign
supposed to um hit in right away or just
just the lowest end I think you were a
hot sauce guy all along Ed you know you
just didn't know no no no no no no
it's good
so when we had actor kumal nanjiani on
the show he put forth this theory that
video games are the only medium and
entertainment that get better year over
year because of the technological
advancements is somebody who's had their
hands so deep in the video game honey
pot since the 1980s does that at all
resonate with you
it does
um
the first Mortal Kombat game
[Music]
we started in 1991
was four people right
um
all right
uh it was four people
one programmer two artists and an audio
guy
the newest one is literally in the
hundreds technology has created an
opportunity for us to make the most
elaborate sets we have actors directors
animators audio Engineers it just it
just goes on and on so the scope is a
hundred times I'd say maybe as big as
the the very first one
and it's all Technology's fault for
better or worse For Better or Worse yeah
is there anything that you miss most
about the old days and then what are you
so happy that you don't have to deal
with anymore
what I miss them most about the old days
is if you have an idea
later that afternoon you can see the
idea you know come through fruition
right you can just see it done now if
you have an idea six month lead oh oh at
least at least it's like it's like you
know
steering the Titanic you know you want
to take a turn you you plan a month
ahead and then you start turning uh so
it was uh there's something about having
an idea off the top of your head and be
able to do it now now it affects you
know 30 people and you have to
borderline get permission to do it
before you uh when you do it even in my
position
[Music]
and here on the five-wing gauntlet we're
doing some time travel here all right
we're going from number one to number
five yeah this is the one I'm getting
the nervous about
oh that's nothing no no I'm sure
it's gonna
okay
they do taste good
it is nice and I'm kind of hungry you
know I don't always come in here hungry
but when I do it it's kind of nice you
know to have the meal here okay I'm uh
suspicious because I I thought I thought
I'd be cracking on the second one for
sure you're gonna be good you're gonna
make it all the way through with not an
ounce of sweat on you all right I can
see her already yet
I'm kind of regret this you got it you
know I'm fascinated by guest characters
you know having Robocop on there having
a Terminator on there spawn Freddy
Krueger what kind of characters do you
look for when deciding to bring a
character from Another Universe into the
Mortal Kombat world that's actually
um it's it's a lot more it's not
technical it's just childish we all
that's why I like it that's why we all
we all grew up uh watching movies from
the 70s 80s and 90s from our standpoint
it is wouldn't it be cool to see
Terminator fighting scorpion wouldn't it
be cool to see RoboCop fighting uh
Sub-Zero and it says as as basic and
simple as that there's no science to it
at some point
um there's legalities can we get the
license to it can we do this but but in
terms of where the idea comes from it's
it's it's a bunch of
adults who are still
trapped in the 70s watching tough guy
movies exactly exactly and want to see
who would win in a fight instead it's
that simple
so this one is the spicy shark here
uh-oh
[Music]
again am I oh okay yeah okay no so this
is one you answered my question it's
kind of sweet up front
and it almost makes you think oh did I
grab the wrong Wing yeah yeah it does
and then the second you think that
the door slams yeah yeah yeah but still
going back in I love it
I love it
so one of my favorite things that's come
out about the new game is that you'll
actually have a Jean-Claude Van Damme
skin for Johnny Cage can you talk about
how that came to be because I imagine
that this is a very validating full
circle moment you know 30 years in the
making it is when we uh oh
um
uh when we made the very first game
our original intention was to make
Van Damme the arcade game right we we
actually you know wanted to see the
words VanDam big there and again
Bloodsport was big and universal Soldier
I think was um
so we we called his his people and we're
like you know we want to make a game
based on Van Damme and
um
I I don't know if he declined or or just
never got to him or something like that
but again this is this is a bunch of you
know
a couple of 20 year old kids 20
something year old kids wanted to make a
video game I could see how Van Damme
would go no no we're not doing this and
not knowing that so we tried a number of
times going back and forth with him
this time we we hit the lottery and we
got him and we actually have his voice
and he's gonna be the Johnny Cage
character and it is like you said it's
the absolute full circle moment that we
had what do you see as the significance
or the role and narrative in a fighting
video game like this so that's actually
one of the hardest things about writing
the story is you know we're going to
give the player like 30 fights so you
have to come up with 30 confrontations
that'll be
um that'll be uh enough for a reason to
fight and we've we've kind of gotten
we've we've stumbled a couple of times
like we'd have you know
Johnny Cage is hitting on somebody and
and Jax is like you know hey cut it out
hey I'm just hitting on her okay let's
fight about it you know
that's not a really good reason to to
well listen fights happen that way
fights happen yeah at a bar or something
like that but but uh so we've had some
really kind of silly ones and we have to
but yeah the stories main function is to
create conflict and let the player
resolve the conflict by beating the crap
out of the other okay the other
character it's only right yeah all right
Ed are you ready to move on here this is
the bomb Beyond Insanity oh man so this
one is crazy okay I'm just okay I'm
letting you know okay off the bat
time
[Music]
it'll be pretty immediate
you won't have to wait for this one oh
man yeah oh man
all right whoa
finish it and uh
by the way
wow that yeah that's the spiciest thing
I've ever had in my life
so like me you're an Alum of the
University of Illinois at
Urbana-Champaign we were talking about
it a little bit outside I know that you
graduated with a degree in mathematics
and computer science I'm curious where
did you think you would go next I can't
imagine you thought like in 1986 that
you're gonna be a video game developer
what'd you say
um no no in 1986 I absolutely knew I was
going to be a video game you know for
yeah I knew wow I knew um
I think when I was like 15 years old or
something a game called defender came
out and um Defender Pac-Man
[Music]
and um
it was
um God it actually gets hot I know it
doesn't stop and then you talk you talk
um you know it provides uh some oxygen
to the fire you know and at the time
um Apple had released you know the Apple
II so so people first got computers in
their hands I had this this Atari 800 oh
my God it's even hotter and um and uh
and once I put a pixel on the screen and
moved it over you know to me it was like
you know hitting a note on a piano and
realizing you can hit three of them and
make a chord you can do this and you can
compose and it was a big moment of like
wow this is what I wanted to do and I
always I always assumed that
um
I would be working at a bank right
writing you know some kind of software
and then making games by myself you know
on a uh as a hobby or something like
that and it turned out that it was um I
lucked out and I got a job in a pinball
company that was also making video games
and that was I've had one job my whole
life right out of school I made one
resume in Champaign Illinois and I've
not made one since which is crazy yeah
yeah my lips are burning
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
you don't have to eat anything else you
did it you know you walked in here a
little bit nervous oh my goodness okay
oh
but to close things out mortal kombat's
made such an indelible imprint I mean
and so many in my generation and here we
are 30 years later still galvanizing
players all over the world so close
things out with your brain on fire mouth
Ablaze I'm gonna hit you with a Mortal
Kombat rapid rapid fire okay
where did the get over here catchphrase
come from
over here we were in the studio
literally off the top of my head I was
like hey let's have the guy throw a
spear and as I was kind of miming it out
I had said you know then he pulls him in
and he says get over here you know and
at that point we did we weren't thinking
of it oh that's that'll be a catchphrase
but later in the um in the audio uh
recording I was there doing some Grunts
and groans and and decided to yell out
get you know get over here that's my
voice and then um that's basically where
it came along
do you have a favorite piece of uh
Mortal Kombat memorabilia or a Keepsake
that you've collected over the years
that's most treasured too yes
um I didn't know it existed
but when they made the first Mortal
Kombat movie for some dangerous reason
they made a Kano knife this gigantic not
safe knife and they branded it and they
put it and they sent me one and I'm the
opposite of somebody who uses knives but
it's it it's really cool looking and so
uh that's my favorite one off the top of
your head without thinking about too
much do you have any sort of an idea for
a hot sauce fatality
um this one and uh I I would say you
know just
Force feeding it to uh to the loser
well you know what Ed
we could not finish him today because he
took on the wings of death lived to tell
the tale and now there's nothing left to
do but roll out the red carpet for you
this camera this camera this camera let
the people know what you have going on
in your life um we have uh September
19th we have Mortal Kombat one that is
coming out it is the 12th version of
Mortal Kombat that we are calling Mortal
Kombat one because we've reset our story
telling it from the actual big bang and
you will see a brand new origin brand
new timeline of a Mortal Kombat universe
and uh as many cool features as we've
ever added and we can't wait for players
to check it out can't wait to play good
job
[Applause]
oh wow man my nose is starting to to run
I'm glad I'm glad uh we finished just in
time yeah yeah yeah I was gonna oh man
Flawless victory
foreign